luc plamandon bonsoir alors en 1976 qui
a reçu un coup de téléphone de michel
berger te proposant d'écrire un opéra
rock c'était pas une comédie musicale
c'est touchante et un autre à autre un
opéra rock sur patricia alors j'avais
travaillé un petit peu plus à rien donné
et puis finalement vous avez fini par
faire starmania maintenant j'ai pas
voulu faire des soirs de patricia
d'abord parce qu'on s'a de prendre
vous ne connaissez pas la fin encore way
pour l'incroyable en fait elle n'était
pas allée puis samedi un homme à décrire
en france c'est une histoire d'une
américaine cnn québécois sinon vers
message n est pas du tout et
sélectivement c'est un très bon sujet
mais maintenant on connaît la fin je
trouve ça encore meilleur sujet mais il
en restait quelque chose autant manière
pérenne et télévisions qui essentielle
d'un terroriste or finalement vph et
starmania bhl s'était créé il ya dix ans
à paris et puis la production est un peu
lourd de la salle un peu
plus grande pour bien le dire et ça pas
été succès que vous escomptiez convient
que ça a été un succès gather et un mois
donc ouais ouais était plein dans un
mois on a vendu 310 album est bon mais
après c'était fini donc c'était
frustrant parce que quand on écrit adam
à l'intéreur une comédie musicale on
veut que ça dure on a envie que ce soit
joué longtemps et c'est la raison pour
laquelle dans leur montée enfin il ya
beaucoup d'anglais et d'américains qui
sont venus voir starmania et qu'il y est
on sait qu'on va le faire en anglais ça
c'est un scoop
ah oui c'est un scoop on pige arrive
d'angleterre avec berger ont sinon on va
le faire à londres l'année prochaine et
ensuite aux états unis ça s'arrose
allez on l'arrosé à la thielle alors à
part ça c'est quoi le projet que tu as
avec berger de avec du pur un truc
danser c'est quoi
avec ou st dupont mais bon c'est
peut-être du temps qui dansera drôle
mais ouais c'est pas quelqu'un d'autre
comme c'est quoi l'histoire un petit
nous comme ça je peux pas le dire c'est
un personnage à dire qu'elle est chère
buisson il t'a fait dire le projet je
leur ai dit pas y aller at avait dit non
mais un peu comme ça je dis moi pourquoi
pas ceux d'hier
en gros un gros bond à 7 1 c'est un show
sur so trendy et bien voilà la prochaine
facture berger avait mis la main sur le
meeting sera sous-titré requiem trois
héros moderne c'est bien donc
il ya un autre canadien qu'elle affiche
en ce moment c'est marc roux 1 ouais
alors c'est un type qui a beaucoup de
succès au québec il a il a fait deux
fois 202 x 200 représentations à
montréal va mal c'est à deux frères avec
cette attaque rock and roll
c'est ce qu'ils disent adieu au calme
loin c'est c'est cette année maurice est
un auteur original et c'est un showman
les jeux vidéo je vis des bas mais je
l'imaginé grecque